[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date a dit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui jean
des cars l'historien des souverains et
des dynasties pour son livre au coeur
des royautés on va revenir sur cléopâtre
la prostituée couronné comme l'appelait
pline l'ancien sur theodora impératrice
de mise en ce qui s'était vraiment
prostituées celle-ci elisabeth 1ère que
l'on appelait la reine vierge sur la
popularité dont jouit aujourd'hui marie
antoinette après avoir été la reine la
plus détestée de notre histoire mais
d'abord on commence par comme à chaque
fois par une image symbolisant notre
époque vous aussi celles que vous avez
choisi jour des cartes elles nous
rappellent effectivement c'est pendant
le mouvement des villes et gilet jaune
je crois bien oui j'ai été scandalisé
par les dégradations dont les sculptures
de rudes notamment ont été victimes car
ça se passait très peu de temps après la
commémoration le centenaire de
l'armistice de 1918
je me disais on a donné au monde une
leçon d'histoire fin de guerre de paix
d'espoir et voilà des abrutis qui
viennent massacrer un travail formidable
sur un monument qui est une synthèse de
l'histoire de fond dario fo il à l'arc
de triomphe a été voulu par napoléon en
1806 ça n'a pas été fini du temps de
lempire l'architecte chalgrin a eu
beaucoup de problèmes
il ya eu deux arcs de triomphe celui-là
est celui du carrousel mais napoléon en
voulez d'autres ensuite changement de
régime le retour des bourbons et c'est
le roi louis philippe et hier qu'ils
vont faire avancer les travaux et
continuer le l'arc de triophe n'est
inauguré qu'en 1836 en respectant
beaucoup de choses qui sont très
délicates
ensuite il y aura
des moments émouvants 1840 le retour des
cendres le cercueil napoléon s'arrêtera
quelques instants sous l'arc de triomphe
aux funérailles de victor hugo il
passera aussi ah oui cercueil absolument
l'oublient souvent
et puis bien sûr la cérémonie du soldat
inconnu
après que
le ministre andré maginot est proposé à
un soldat de
choisir au hasard de huit cercueils
celui qui serait choisi pour incarner si
je puis dire le soldat inconnu il a
déposé une fleur et donc c'est en 1921
1922 il a été amené donc il ya toute une
histoire à travers plusieurs régimes
politiques de la france symboliser et
j'étais choqué on est vraiment sa cage
et ses sculptures et ses monuments
ça a été réparée de sa a été réparée
mais j'ai pensé que ça donnait une image
à l'égard de nos alliés notamment par
exemple les russes alliés de la première
guerre mondiale
une image déplorable car dans ces pays
on a le respect de l'histoire quel que
soit le régime est bien que mosson
[Musique]
dans des cas où publié donc chez perrin
au coeur des royautés sont les récits
tirés de votre podcast du même nom sur
europe 1 qui rencontre un très grand
succès comme la plupart de vos livres
d'ailleurs vous êtes le spécialiste des
trains de luxe et des têtes couronnées
alors est-ce que c'est arrivé par hasard
parce que est ce que vous êtes
monarchiste par tradition familiale
la famille pérusse d'écart appartient la
noblesse du xiiie siècle mais votre père
guy des cars était un célèbre romancier
il a vendu des millions d'exemplaires de
romans qui se passait presque uniquement
dans les classes populaires et votre
fille que laurence des cars vient d'être
nommée présidente du musée du louvre le
plus grand musée du louvre veut le plus
grand musée du monde qui semblait donc
être le seul à nourrir une telle passion
pour les rois et les reines ça vous via
doux mais c'est un aspect humain je
trouve intéressant d'avoir des hommes et
des femmes qui selon les régimes et les
constitutions vont incarner l'état sans
les aléas de l'élection directement
concernés si vous voulez je trouve que
formula par exemple il ya une femme dont
on ne parle pas beaucoup mais qui fait
savoir ses idées c'est la reine
margrethe de danemark qui règne depuis
1972 est une femme qui souveraine qui
m'a fait l'honneur de me recevoir l on
m'avait dit si ça se passe bien la reine
vous proposera de vous asseoir quand ça
se passe mal les gens restent debout
dieu merci elle m'a proposé de m'asseoir
mais quand on n'est pas content de son
premier ministre
il reste debout bonds est une femme
remarquable et a quand même produit
simone de beauvoir en danois par exemple
une grande même liberté elle-même avec
le prince henrik et qui a une grande
liberté de ton et une grande de qui
je veux dire quand elle a reçu le
président macron elle me dit monsieur le
président de la république que nous
sommes heureux de vous accueillir nous
sommes un des rares pays avec lequel
vous n'avez jamais été en guerre
bon c'est rare souligné beaucoup
d'humour on m'avait son mari le prince
henri bon j'aime beaucoup ces gens qui
sont là pour un certain temps alors est
évident que le roi de suède très peu
pouvoir mais pendant la pandémie c'est
lui qui apparaissait à la télévision
pour dire nous nous sommes trompés
ça ne va pas il faut changer et c'est
donc un espèce de d'incarnation sens
propre qui me paraît intéressante et je
suis contre le quinquennat en france la
république et concours oui c'est
beaucoup trop court on n'a pas le temps
regardez ce qui se passe le président
élu est à peine arrivée qu'il est en
campagne
je trouve que alors évidemment on a le
cas de la reine elizabeth 2 2 depuis
1953 date de son avènement en vain de
son couronnement de son sacre pourquoi
est elle aussi présente
parce qu'elle a eu une idée
révolutionnaire à l'époque accepté que
cérémonie soit télévisé
certes il était contre et c'était en
noir et blanc
mais la pellicule en couleurs avait été
quand même imprimé et on a pu le voir
dans des salles de cinéma gelé vu à
l'époque j'étais très jeune
c'était un spectacle donc la monarchie
britannique est devenu avec elle un
spectacle d'ailleurs unique en son genre
vous devrez donc atteint déjà très
jeunes parce que pour aller au cinéma
assister au sacre de la reine elizabeth
ii alors qu'on est français absolue
vraiment aimé ça oui mais c'était
intéressant parce que je pensais si vous
voulez que il ya eu tellement d'horreurs
je veux dire de penser la guillotine
installé
sur l'actuelle place de la concorde ex
place louis-xiv place de la révolution
avec des tricoteuses et des gens qui se
régalait
de la guillotine quelle que soit
l'opinion je veux dire que c'est quand
même effrayant il s'est régalé avant
d'aider des tortures et supplier bien
entendu au régicide je pense que
franchement c'était épouvantable
alors moi je me souviens d'une chose
intéressante le président mitterrand qui
était un homme très cultivé qui m'avait
envoyé des lettres et comme à d'autres
écrivains absolument passionnante
considérant que la mort louis saez était
à l'origine le goût de drames en france
avait autorisé une manifestation pour le
bicentenaire de la mort de louis saez
cérémonie sur la place de la concorde où
l'ambassadeur des états unis est venu
avec une grande gerbe de fleurs pour
dire au roi louis saez les états unis
reconnaissant et beaucoup de socialistes
de l'époque y compris le préfet de
police étaient choqués et il ya eu des
milliers de personnes des dizaines de
milliers de personnes et pas le moindre
incident c'est tête en silence je
trouvais que ça avait une certaine
allure voilà et c'était un rappel
historique parce que l'indépendance
américaine a coûté très cher à la france
oui et peut-être même été une des causes
de la révolution du mas dieu ses fruits
l'été nous sépare dont il veut que les
causes étaient étaient nombreux alors
revenons sur un certain nombre de vos
personnages de ce dernier livre et
commençons par cléopâtre qu'on connaît
tous mais on sait moins que pline
l'ancien fameuse historiens romains
l'appelait la prostituée couronnées ou
la reine et pour conserver un
semblant d'indépendance à l'egypte
et c'était dur d'ailleurs après sa mort
l'egypte ne leur a plu soit
l'indépendance pendant vingt siècles
je crois que ma question c'est pour eux
on a l'impression qu'elle était prête à
tout et hop a trait notamment à s'offrir
ou aux conquérants romain en place
d'abord césar avec quels freins enfants
puis marc antoine avec qui elle en aura
3 puis octave qui va repousser les
avances et c'est pour ça qu'elle va se
suicider mais je veux dire par là est ce
qu elle était vraiment la reine
qu'on a décrit je crois surtout si vous
voulez ceci n'empêche pas d'ailleurs
qu'elle était
on la présente comme une reine d'egypte
mais les d'origine grecque macédonienne
c'est tout le malentendu le drame de de
cléopâtre c'est qu'en fait elle elle
représente une egypte qui n'est plus
l'egypte pharaonique de des grandes
dynasties elle essaie de la prolonger et
dans le fond par souci de colonisation
de rome voilà elle se glisse dans cette
histoire je pense quand même qu'elle
devait être très sensuelle à défaut
d'être vraiment belle on n'a que peu de
documents et on a les commentaires de
pascal sur son aide beaucoup
will est ce qu'on voit là mais c'est
mieux et on a retrouvé récemment il dans
des fouilles récentes en egypte un buste
qui pourrait être celui qui tient pas
pour les archéologues sont en train de
discuter mais ce qui est formidable
c'est d'être apparue comme une
égyptienne une reine d'égypte alors
qu'elles ne l'étaient pas et je trouve
ça montre très bien l'histoire de de
rome essayant de s'étendre dans le monde
méditerranéen
il ya ensuite théodore à l'impératrice
de byzance elle essaie vraiment
prostituées darwin jeunesse elle était
actrice les actrices étaient des
prostituées absolue elle ne pouvait
d'ailleurs pas épouser des patriciens
elle va parvenir à épouser quand même
l'héritier du trône de justinien juive
aurait nié ensemble ils vont régner
ensemble c'est assez étonnant c'est un
couple formidable dont on peut voir les
images au sens propre à ravenne
aujourd'hui dans ces mosaïques exonéré
là c'est un couple au pouvoir ce qui est
formidable c'est qu'elle vient d'une
famille évidemment
de l'origine la plus basse avec
l'atmosphère de l'hippodrome à
constantinople enfin aujourd'hui
istanbul
et quand on pense à ce qui s'est passé
constantinople istanbul et que je
repense à sainte sophie
ces combats de d'une europe chrétienne
du moyen âge je dirais plus tard
maintenu de byzance
il disparaît et qu'on recherche
enfin tout ça est fascinant je trouve
que en effet c'est une prostituée qui
est à la fois un grand esprit pratique
et qui a compris l'importance de l'image
très important et elle va d'ailleurs
fasciné les peintres un wii était mieux
quelques quelques exemples et puis
surtout c'est un grand règne justinien
et theodora c'est vraiment c'est
l'apogée 2011
oui l'apogée de byzance avec un code
avec des articles avec des zi qui vont
réglementer lempire pendant des
décennies c'est très très important je
le dire moi je suis chaque fois que je
les dents dans ces régions jeter frappée
par l'importance de l'organisation de
l'esprit le des textes qui ont été
conçus alors il avait un protocole très
très bizarre tous les deux c'est un
couple assez étonnant il fallait se
prosterner il fallait les voir tous les
deux en même temps il y avait une sorte
de rivalité mais ça a secoué le monde
byzance est devenu un rêve est alors pas
passer deux sex-symbol que son cléopâtre
et theodora qui a été l'objet de
nombreux films aussi un teaser avancions
ans opératrice de byzance a beaucoup
fait rêver oui y'a lisabeth première
elle c'est la fille d'henri 8 et d'anne
boleyn donc anne boleyn qui est une des
une des six femmes n'auraient 8 qui a
été décapitée celle ci et les premières
va régner 44 ans et elle est surnommée
la reine vierge est ce qu'elle est
vraiment vierge alors je suis quand même
mal placé pour vous donner un certificat
mai
beaucoup d'hommes dans sa vie mais ce
qui me fascine moi c'est son ce cerveau
son esprit politique parce que pendant
trois mois
sur son bureau au milieu d'une foule de
papier
c'est très bien qu'il y a le wawa
l'ordre d'exécution d'un sa cousine nice
christian
c'est là et qu'il faut qu'elles signent
pour que l'exécution ait lieu et quand
elle signera elle dira après angers
signé ce papier sans voir ce serait
c'est un monument d'hypocrisie grandiose
un très grand cerveau politique il faut
rappeler aussi que c'est la souveraine
d'une époque artistique intellectuel
incarné par shakespeare qui met en scène
au théâtre la comédie du pouvoir les
drames du pouvoir c'est même fascinant
avec une angleterre conquérante qui va
réussir à dominer lava cible à mada
espagnole et sa virginité que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure va fasciner
quand même alors virginité réelle ou
supposée mais m'a fasciné ce
contemporain et notamment ses amis rossé
marin parce que lorsqu'ils vont arriver
à bordés dans le sud du continent
nord-américain l'état le futur état dans
lequel ils vont s'installer sera appelée
la virginie et la première colonie
anglais la première colonie anglaise en
hommage à la vertu de la souffre quand
même comme quoi savait l'importance à
71,1 gabrielle d'estrées c'est le grand
amour d'henri iv elle elle est l'héroïne
d'un tableau très célèbre que l'on voilà
qui est le signe c'est sa soeur à côté
d'elle les ciels lui passe le st c'est
pour montrer qu'elle est enceinte
c'est donc un tableau très important
alors c'est typiquement français
c'est le règne mais alors gabrielle
d'estrées c'est le grand amour d'henri
iv mais à 18 ans elle avait déjà eu
plusieurs amants tous riches et
puissants comme quoi la virginité des
femmes leur soumission l'a toujours
beaucoup plus complexe que ce que l'on
nous raconte aujourd'hui
enfin elle a et devait avoir un fort
tempérament qu'elle était très libre sur
8 août mais d'ailleurs poussé henri iv
qui n'a pas vraiment aimé mais d'après
ce qu'on sait il l'a repoussée parce
qu'il sentait un peu trop live risque
elle a dit je comprends il au bout de
huit jours il disait à ce sera
aujourd'hui jour de ben oui donc
peut-être quelques femmes que ils
prenaient leurs distances pendant ce
temps là mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant parce que ça donne avec un
côté vaudeville les amants n'est ce pas
qui henri iv et l'amant qui sont sous
l'ihs qui se cache à tour de rôle enfin
on est dans un théâtre
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie vont henri iv
qui était un personnage tout à fait
passionnant avec un ministre passionnant
mais gabrielle d'estrées et surtout ce
mystère de sa mort est ce qu'elle a été
empoisonné est-ce que c'est des
volontaires trop jeune pour être reine
est là il faut il faut résumer parce que
tout le monde le sait que des pas son
destin
henri iv et comme chacun sait marié à la
reine margot mais une victoire semble
ici non réparés depuis très longtemps je
lille tombe fou amoureux de gabrielle
d'estrées ils veulent épouser mon lui
dit que c'est de la folie parce que
politiquement ce serait un vrai problème
elle lui donne quand même trois enfants
et elle veut se faire épouser lui fini
par lui dire ok et au moment même alors
qui va l'épouser qu'elle attend le
quatrième enfant de d'henri iv
elle meurt on pense à ce moment là
qu'elle a été empoisonnée d'autres
disent depuis qu'elle aura été victime
d'une crampe si vous à dire une
infection due à sa grille et qui noircit
le sang les voyants sont possibles elles
étaient très très jolie et elle a été un
enchantement pour henry cap tout en
étant je dirait quelqu'un elle devait
l'avez compris son tempérament
de conquérant permanent enfin qui il
n'arrêtait pas c'est très émouvant henri
iv d'autant que il a un pressentiment
quand même parce que y va demander à ce
que marine médicis épouse deviennent
régente il file le fait la veille de son
assassinat
on dit d'ailleurs qu'elle a peut-être
trempé marie ministre en paix dans
l'assassinât d'henri iv à l'aller avec
les médicis comme brisé mais lier au
moment-même vous le dites dans votre
livre moment même où il promet à
gabrielle d'estrées de l'épouser oui il
est en tractation et vous la famille
médicinales et l on l'appellera la
banquière bancaire elle est arrivée avec
des deux choses essentielles c'est
astrologues et l'invention de la future
gastronomie réel d'alien mais importés
en france il complète la fourchette
ce qui n'était pas du luxe oui
effectivement la marie-antoinette alors
là pour moi c'est une énigme et marie
antoinette
parce que sa popularité devenu
absolument incroyable aujourd'hui en
france et pas seulement en france alors
que l'aïe alors qu'elle a été la l'arène
la plus haïe de notre histoire et on
sait bien que tout lui pardonner sa
superficialité son inconséquence sa
mauvaise influence sur louis saez parce
que ce toute influence qu'elle ait pu
avoir été catastrophique pour ce pauvre
louis saez qui était faible de toute
façon alors comment expliquez-vous tout
est bien jeu et pas seulement à cause de
sofia coppola dont la popularité de nom
je pense qu'il ya une raison c'est que
grâce au travail des historiens
on a pu mesurer les drames des enfants
du couple
il faut si vous voulez simplement
rappelé qu'au moment de l'ouverture des
états généraux
la cour est en deuil et que marie
antoinette va subir choc de mort
d'enfants ses enfants nés maladif dans
le dos fort dauphin pendant les états
généraux y en ait deux généraux donc
c'est anne la cour était en deuil
il ya des témoignages qu'on a retrouvée
qui sont absolument bouleversant parce
que ça ça montre une situation
épouvantable que le peuple n'a pas su
vous ne voulez pas voir puisque là elle
était mal conseillé mauvaise influence
alors il ya des choses qu'on peut
remettre en perspective
par exemple on dit qu'elles étaient
frivoles et qu'elle se faisait faire
trop de vêtements de parts aux waratahs
et prospère les beaucoup dans votre
livre qui était la modiste de la reine
la modiste qui a lancé une formule à mon
avis grandiose la mode c'est ce qui a
été oublié
grâce à ses formidables et marie
antoinette son problème était d'être
devenu dauphine trop jeunes ne pas avoir
été préparé à schönbrunn par
l'impératrice m'intéresse au maire à la
cour de france aux favorites de ce passe
mal avec louis caset madame du barry
l'économie de favorite non il avait déjà
nombre a vraiment et donc leur drame
c'est que physiquement ils ne
s'entendent pas lui c'est elle qu'il
faudra quand même que le frère marié
antonette viennent expliquer à son beau
frère louis saez comment s'y prendre si
j'ose dire
donc les c'est arrivé à dallas si vous
voulez aux mamans au moment de son
procès marionnettes et d'une très très
grande dignité devant toutes les
horreurs qu'on va déverser sur elle y
compris les horreurs d'inceste sa
fameuse fera j'en appelle à toutes les
mères sa frappe et des gens et même un
révolutionnaire de talent
graphique comme david qui fait son
dernier portrait dans la charrette qui
l'a conduit de la conciergerie à la
guillotine a été sensible à son allure
et puis si vous voulez après on s'est
aperçu que bombe allait elle était trop
jeune
évidemment fersen on a pu repas de
documents de preuve socialiste et sa
maîtresse ou pas oui on ne sait pas une
passion oui
ce qui est terrible dans le fond c'est
qu'elles étaient à priori coupables de
tous et le monument c'est la sphère du
collier où elle est totalement innocent
mais comme le dira stefan zweig
puisqu'elle s'en mêle
elle est donc coupe mais vous vous
arrêtez sur ce tableau qu'on voit la
blood elisabeth vigée-lebrun commandé à
elisabeth par la reine marie antoinette
en 1785
oui et donc qui la représente avec tous
ses enfants harry en même temps il
reprend le modifier à nabeul et voilà il
ya le berceau vide
le petit enfant qui montre le berceau
vide parce qu'il est mort a annoncé ce
tableau qu'elle a été sauvée quai qui
résume je dirais les drames tant de
difficultés pour être enceinte en doute
les raisons qu'on a dit
le problème des enfants malades maladif
qui ne résiste pas qu'ils sont sans
doute victime de tuberculose osseuse
et ce tableau absolument bouleversant
avec l'enfant qui montre celui qui
manque
ouais c est qui n'est pas encore celui
qui va mourir on how pendant l'héritage
nerfs on en reste à ses yeux le petit
bébé qui venait d'être ce qui est
terrible dans le cas de louis saez
civisme seul voyage qu'il a à faire
en france seul voyage aller voir le port
de cherbourg
il a été très populaire et n'étaient
jamais sortis dans font les gens les
français ne le connaissais pas donc et
quand on l'a vu même son bourreau sera
impressionné par sa taille parce que il
mesurait dit on 1 m 92 en fait le swiss
re est grande très fort et son bureau
son robot
voir reculer dans le voyant c'est drôle
parce que dans les films on leur
présente toujours petit rondouillard ce
qui fait partie de la légende de
fabriquer bien sûr c'est quand même
assez étonnant mais alors ouais c'est ça
va vous explications de me prive pas me
suffire pour expliquer ça alors ça ce
que vous racontez c'est vrai pour
marie-antoinette on va dire au moment de
la sortie du film avec michel morgon oui
tout à coup on se rend compte que cette
femme est une mère qu'elle est humaine
et qu'on a été trop dur avec elle
mais aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus que
ça c'est la mode c'est rose bertin
peut-être gc c'est une fêtarde con qu'on
adore mais oui il y avait à l'opéra
parce que elle s'ennuyait
elle avait l'interdiction de faire de la
politique sa mère l'impératrice marie
thérèse me disait attention attention
parce que entre la maison d'autriche et
la monarchie française y est
mutuellement de contentieux n'est pas la
peine de remettre elle n'a pas toujours
été à droite évidemment mais elle
n'avait pas l'habitude de la vie de cour
des courtisans des libelles et cetera
chez l'impératrice marie thérèse on
était beaucoup plus en famille était
mieux mieux organiser six une raie et
l'a donc là sans doute mal réagi elle
apparut frivole mais je pense voyez vous
que c'est ce couple lady ailleurs
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment retrouvé à la
prison du temple c'est là où le couple
et où marie-antoinette montre une
une grande fermeté d'esprit c'est elle
qui va prendre la direction des
événements c'est ce que leur façon leur
condamnation et leur mort va valoriser
d'une certaine manière est
respectivement leur vie entière
ils sont mieux en condamner en accusé
puis condamné
oui il se comporte mieux quand souverain
oui c'est change d'avis en permanence
dans les lits ridiculement faible
actuellement beaucoup trop faible pas
sensé ces moments-là mécanique passionné
par la marine ses derniers mots et ce
qu'on a des nouvelles de monsieur de
lapérouse si c'est à dire qu'il n'était
pas sa place entre l'horloger
l'explorateur théorique qu'il voulait
être
il s'ennuyait avec le pouvoir politique
et marie thérèse se sentait une
étrangère et antoinette mariétou
pardonnez moi et marie antoinette se
sentait une étrangère
elle avait 16 ans il avait fallu lui
apprendre le français à toute vitesse
enfin tout ça n'était pas programmé si
je puis dire préparer et est sans doute
ce qui nous attendrait aussi c'est que
sais tu ce que les anglais appellent
close au sco c'est à dire c'est vraiment
un cheval de mode et un rien l'habille
oui elle que je ne sais pas si elle
était aussi will qu'on commence je mets
le mode vous avez raison de le rappeler
parce que lorsqu'elle a voulu apparaître
d'une façon simple avec ce qu'on
appelait une robe de gaulle une robe de
campagne de fermières ce a fortement
déplu
on voulait que la reine représente la
reine mais quand elle a représenté la
reine on le lui a reproché donc cet état
c'est infernal et et visiblement elle
avait l'air plus joli que nous ils
étaient ses prédécesseurs reine de
france ne sont pas spécialement réputé
dans leur beauté en ont c'est vrai est
elle si c'est la seule et je pense
qu'elle avait
un charme fait un teint de porcelaine
d'après les témoins très très timide
évidemment face aux favorites quand vous
avez en face de vous une professionnelle
comme la du barry
c'est un peu difficile et encore une
fois l'atmosphère de la cour de vienne
étaient tellement famille
le mot favorite n'existait pas donc
c'était un autre monde et on l'a
qualifié tout de suite d'étrangères il
faut dire que le vieux contentieux
franco autrichien n'était pas en sa
faveur y avait eu anne d'autriche aussi
mais il est plutôt espagnol c'est plutôt
un plus tôt voilà mais anne d'autriche
paris antoine est sûre à marie-louise
jouer avec napoléon
oui c'est jamais facile d'être d'être
une reine de france qu'on en revienne si
j'étais là et on le verra aussi avec
l'impératrice eugénie une espagnole une
espagnole qui en plus veut réhabiliter
marie-antoinette ça ne se fait pas on
fait une pause dans des cas on se
retrouve juste après on va s'intéresser
ben justement à l'impératrice eugénie
alors jean des cas revenons-en à
l'impératrice eugénie elle a 23 ans
quand elle rencontre louis napoléon
bonaparte qui en a 41 qui est président
de la république il va attendre un peu
pour la demander en mariage il va
l'épouser elle doit devenir
l'impératrice en france alors à la plus
belle collection de bijoux d'europe et
met alors à une très mauvaise réputation
encore aujourd'hui génie de montijo
puisqu'on lui reproche d'avoir poussé
napoléon à intervenir au mexique et on
lui reproche également de l'avoir poussé
à faire la guerre à la prusse qui a été
une catastrophe comme chacun sait et
c'est vrai que le elle est associée au
moment où le lempire français enfin le
second empire rayonne le plus ça voudra
comme louise et c'est l'inauguration du
canal de suez qui a été creusé par son
cousin ferdinand peu de peps elle est
sur le bateau napoléon n'est pas là elle
est sur le bateau qui inaugure le canal
on né en 1869 en appréciant que le
lempire français était à son apogée et
un an après catastrophe
tout est fini alors ce qui est
dramatique c'est que l'impératrice n'a
pas fait assez attention à la santé de
napoléon iii
exaspéré par ces maîtresses qui disait
vous épuisez l'empereur
avec un certain humour quand elle
apprenait qu'il avait une nouvelle
liaison et qu'il avait le portrait de là
la jeune femme sur son bureau elle brise
le portrait renens désormais il faudra
vous contenter de l'original même si
saint esprit et cette femme
très courageuse qui après 1870 ne se
plaindra jamais ils vivront en exil je
crois que la photo est annoncé plus tôt
sa non non ça c'est les petits éléments
mais si vous voulez vivre à londres
voilà c'est il ya un souvenir de ma
famille que je me permet d'évoquer mais
grand angle il me l'a raconté un jour de
1910 au château de compiègne fait très
chaud dans ta mois d'août est beaucoup
demandé voici qu'on voit arriver deux
dame en noir et il suffit de messieurs
canotiers
l une des deux dames en noir à l'entrée
ayant pris son billet s'arrête et on
pense qu'elle a un malaise à cause à
chaleur non pour reconnaît la piraterie
ce génie qui n'était pas venu depuis des
soirées de compiègne depuis 1869 et qui
voyait l'ancienne porte de la chambre de
son fils le prince impérial morts en
afrique du sud au combattre les zoulous
sous l'uniforme britannique
à bonaparte sous une forme britannique
là c'était bon or l'impératrice eugénie
a eu avec beaucoup de défauts bien sûr
une très grande dignité
elle ne s'est jamais plaint lors la
commis des fautes notamment le mexique
mais y'a une chose assez extraordinaire
et j'ai retrouvé dans des documents de
famille c'est quand en 1918
les américains rechignent lors de la
conférence de versailles à accélérer la
restitution de l'alsace lorraine et
elles fouillent tous ses papiers pour
retrouver ça dure des jours et des jours
pour retrouver une lettre du roi
guillaume premier de plus le premier
empereur allemand
couronné à l'adversité à la versailles
1871 qui lui dit le maintien de l'alsace
lorraine sous la domination prussienne
n'a pas d'intérêt et cetera nous n'en
voulons pas et elle va faire porter
cette clé est à clemenceau qui se dit
mais qu'est ce qu'elle veut quand ces
vieilles bigotes catholique gardait
toujours vivant
ça c'est extraordinaire et elle dira ce
n'était pas ma guerre celle là quatorze
bon donc je voulais et les elle est
morte en 1920 gênante en 1928 très
longtemps après le raid à l'audience
c'est cette une femme qui n'est dans la
belgique n'existe pas quand
stade al et mérimée vont lacaune est
petit et vont lui raconter un waterloo
l'espagne et cetera
eux mêmes ayant connu des gens qui
avaient connu la fin du règne de louis
saez des jantes oz un geste assez
extraordinaire et cette femme qui parle
avec cet accent qui va admettre napoléon
iii comme mari alors qu'elle sait très
bien que êtes un cavaleur pas possible
et qu'elle est loin d'un accent
d'ailleurs voilà et oui un empereur
français qui aura toujours l'accent
allemand toujours un islam en suisse
allemand oui il avait gardé la
nationalité
ce qu'on appelle les lettres de
citoyenneté est alors à ce mot
formidable parce que d'appeler en 3 veut
évidemment coucher avec elle mais
comment fait on pour vous épousez dans
pour vous jusqu'à votre chien votre
chambre on passe par l'hôtel à uteem sûr
il s'agit du mariage non j'ai cru que
cette femme était très digne après
toutes ses erreurs ses fautes
son courage aussi elle a fait beaucoup
pour les femmes
elle s'est battue pour que l'éducation
féminine
si vous voulez soient prodigués aux
jeunes filles pour leur donner des
métiers il ya une fondation qui existe
toujours d'ailleurs qu'elle a fondé
alors évidemment ce n'était pas une
littéraire pas une intellectuelle mais
c'était une femme très courageuse face à
l'épidémie de choléra tout le monde
avait peur et elle était très forte et
je trouve qu'on avait été prêt comme il
est et espagnol on a vu l'autrichien
elle le portait le malheur ben alors oui
on l'est on l'accuse d'avoir poussé le
d'amis dont trois à la garde avec la
prusse c'est pas prouvée en revanche
elle s'est retrouvée régenter elle était
vraiment la région où il appuie selon
lui les partis sur son cheval absolument
malade mais elle lui aurait interdit de
revenir à paris le risque elle lui
disait vous pouvez revenir que
victorieux réveil taille ne reviendra
jamais mais la vraie faute de génie à
mon avis c'est de ne pas avoir tenu à
ses comptes quitte à se fâcher de l'état
de santé effroyable de l'empereur
n'était pas en état de tenir à cheval
pendant un quart d'heure puisqu'il avait
un calcul dans la vessie c'était une
douleur atroce ce qu il a fait de lui un
homme meuse qui s'est sacrifiée qui
aurait voulu mourir à sedan où on en la
rendant les échauffourées et je trouve
que jenny alors accueilli le défaut
supplémentaires de vouloir réhabiliter
marie-antoinette s'était pas adroit
parce que après l'autrichienne
l'espagnol et pourtant elle a adoré la
france
ça a été très dur avec son son seul fils
voilà qui morts sous l'uniforme anglais
c'est assez formidable la reine victoria
été très frappé par ce destin
sauf qu'elle est une grande dignité dans
l'épreuve d'ailleurs le futur auteur du
guépard de dire à cathy verra tout jeune
garçon cette femme qui représente le
malheur alors elle a été l'illustration
d'une france rayonnante remarquablement
équipe et sur le plan économique
industrielle grâce à napoléon iii
les chemins de fer les bateaux les
livraisons de denrées alimentaires les
livraisons du commerce les français liés
entre eux alors qu'ils ne se
connaissaient pas les travaux de la
ministre de l'économie
oui absolument voilà donc la prusse et
est très jalouse du rayonnement
je dirai à tous points de vue de cette
fête parisienne alors revenons-en aux
casses ici puisque pourquoi est-ce qu'on
se passionne pour cette femme pour si si
il y avait consacré trois livres j'en ai
trouvé au moins 3 6 6 1 paiera tri66 la
fatalité et puis si si et françois
joseph le
le évidemment il ya tous les films j'ai
beaucoup vécu avec elle et j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à tuer dire que donc à
ce que moi je vous dis mais qu'elle
aurait at-elle pourquoi parce que à la
chute du communisme
j'ai voulu j'étais jeune journaliste à
paris match et voulu aller en hongrie
où on m'avait dit il ya des documents
qui ont été conservés etc
et j'ai trouvé des documents
extraordinaire qui révise un peu la
position alors on sait qu'elle avait une
tente et belle-mère caractériel
et si ci va se venger en étant la reine
de hongrie de la reine des endroits mal
très grande fierté que mes livres soit
traduit en hongrois
parce que j'ai rappelé que même au temps
du communisme dur celui dont on se
souvient en 56 notamment à budapest
si vous voulez trois ans après la mort
de staline mais du temps de staline
même les ponts elisabeth le pont rg bête
en hongrois n'étaient pas des baptisés
tellement elle était populaire ça aurait
été une faute donc une femme qui n'avait
rien à voir avec cette couronne et qui
va accepter d'être la reine des hongrois
à défaut d'être une impératrice aimé
puisque elle se sentait mal à vienne je
trouve c'est un destin formidable alors
elle était effectivement jolie cavalière
indépendante à un régime alimentaire
assez fou ce qui est jeu qui est superbe
c'est que ce pauvre françois joseph qui
aurait dû épouser sa soeur sera très
malheureux de l'avoir toujours partir
elle tenait sa de son cousin louis ii de
bavière
c'était une mouette elle était toujours
en voyage l'espérait ceux fixés par
exemple à corfou et ça durera quelques
années elle partait tout le temps elle
voulait être indépendante et voilà c'est
dernière chose
sa dernière manifestation d'état civil
si j'ose dire
le matin du 10 septembre 1898 à genève
elle fait des courses
et avec sa dame d'honneur et un policier
de la ville de genève
elle entre dans des magasins et on va
lui demander de signer le livre d'or
elle signera partout hergé bête reine de
hongrie
donc cessons c'est sous cette identité
eu quelques heures plus tard elle sera
assassiné à genève par des anarchistes
et françois joseph lui même grâce à 6,6
bénéficie en tout cas pour ceux qui
regardent les films avec romy schneider
une aura romantique alors que c'est
quand même une catastrophe qui va régner
68 ans il ne connaîtra que des revers
que de riz finira par mener son pays
cette catastrophe qui est la première
guerre mondiale d'eau qui sortira briser
la fin de l' empire austro chaque fois
que je vois un badie seul si vous voulez
la maison françois joseph passer ses
vacances
son bureau où il a signé l'ordre de
mobilisation générale après l'attentât
de sarajevo sous un buste de 6,6 j'ai
envie de me dire que si elle avait été
vivant elle lui aurait dit non ne fais
pas ça tu vas tout détruire baisse était
un soldat il vivait en uniforme étaient
stupides
voilà il était trop il aimait l'ordre le
désordre le déstabiliser et puis à tous
les drames dont la conspiration entre
guillemets éventuellement meilleure
ligne mais qui est quand même quelque
chose de très très fort oui c'est un
empereur qui était trop bien trop
mondain mais que j'aime beaucoup comme
spectateur de des désastres oui s'il en
avait effectivement l'habitude
katia dolgorouki qui est la maîtresse
puis l'épousé morganatique du tsar
alexandre 2
elle aussi a été interprétée par romy
schneider aussi des moyens curd jürgens
dans le rôle du jazz alors elle sa desta
assez extraordinaire c'est une jeune
femme de 17 ans de la noblesse déjà
argenté qui est l institut ce money
avec qu'ils rencontrent les arts elle
devient sa maîtresse un ou deux cents
ans plus tard est une espèce de passions
extraordinaires qui les lie très
sensuelle ils s'écrivent des lettres
formidable elle l'appelle mon cher mari
veuillez et ça va durer comme ça part
très très longtemps à 15 ans et il va
l'épouser
deux mois après que la tsarine dont il
épouse stubbins discrètement goitia ça
malheureusement à eux il va mourir dans
ces bas où il était déjà mort victime
lui aussi d'un attentat terrain tu as we
bien les plantes les terroristes
visaient aux vidéos les premiers
attentats on a vu des femmes d'ailleurs
lancé des grenades et tout est donc ça a
été terrible et elle finira sa vie à
nice sur la riviera cette côte d'azur
qui sera et qui était déjà très
fréquenté non seulement garder anglais
mais par les russes et c'est à elle
c'est une belle histoire katia ya fait
scandale bien sûr et alexandre 2 quand
même on a été très dur d'une certaine
façon avec lui voilà hazard qui arrive à
supprimer le servage et et on lui en
veut d'avoir libéré la population russe
était en état de servage depuis des
siècles c'est pourtant moins bête de la
bande son père était une catastrophe
nicolas 2 sera absolument et donc ce
sera terrible pour le futur le chiot
nicolas 2 qu'il y avait depuis je n'aime
pas les des révolutionnaires parce que
mon grand-père a été révolutionnaire en
supprimant l'esclave âge et tout ce
qu'on lui a rendu ces deux d'essayer de
le tuer voilà une chose mais vous savez
ce qui est intéressant c'est pardon
c'est que des russes ont un sens de
l'histoire tellement extraordinaire je
ne dis pas ça parce que je me trouve ici
mais qui m'a toujours fasciné
vous avez j'ai assisté il ya trois ans
un à quatre ans la remise sur socle
d'une statue d'alexandre 3 le colosse
l'homme de l'alliance franco-russe
sibir ce qu un de ces ponts jetés sur
les grands fleuves russe est à 300
mètres de là vous avez devant l'opéra
une statue de lénine
je trouve que c'est une leçon
et les guides les gens du tourisme j'ai
interrogé m'ont dit mais c'est normal
monsieur des gares les deux font partie
de l'histoire
chez nous aussi on a des statuts de nos
rois et de nos révolutionnaires
oui mais je ne l'aurais aimé une statue
de louis saez devant le musée de la
marine
j'en ai pas vus et un mot sur elizabeth
2 parce que vous lui consacrez quand
même plus de 100 pages
non parce que ses fonctions de la
royauté pourquoi autant j'ai
l'impression que c'est cette série the
corn qui l'a rendu romanesque alors
elizabeth pour otaku cette petite dame
qui avait l'air sans grand relief
on s'est aperçu qu'elle avait traversé
des trucs pas possibles et qu'elles sont
et est toujours sorti à la force de la
delahaye de la chronique tué parce que
c'est une femme très disciplinés vous
savez puis elle tient de sa mère que
j'ai connus qui est de la personne un
geste ordinaire
là les partenaires georges si c'était
extraordinaire elle est venue chez une
de mes tantes en périgord
la voilà la la maman doit la maman qui
est à la suite d'une erreur de services
de sécurité les deux agents de scotland
yard chargé de la protection de la reine
mère qui était menacé par quelques
agités se retrouve obligé dit-on d'aller
logés à l'auberge du village ce qui fait
désordre et la reine mère arrive nous
sommes aux années 1970 avec un verre de
gin bien plein et diam attentes mais
simone je ne risque rien hitler et
staline mans watts et qu'un tempérament
alors chez elizabeth ii il y a un sens
extraordinaire du devoir elle a fait
donc de la monarchie un spectacle par la
télévision puisque on a pu assister à
son sacre son couronnement et depuis
c'est devenu spectacle on connaît plus
ou moins réussies selon les cas mais il
ya une un sens du devoir des choses qui
se font qu'ils ne se font pas je pense
qu'elle a elle a beaucoup souffert des
dernier esclandre de megan surtout il a
été très vexé que megan considère alors
que la reine l'envoyaient en tant que
chef du commonwealth dans plusieurs
états africains anciennes colonies
britanniques ou pas
en dix ans était un des hochets non pour
la reine c'est très important parce qu
elle même l'avait fait d'ailleurs même
l'avait fait et le jour de sa majorité
20 21 avril 1947 elle se trouve au cap
en afrique du sud elle prononce un
discours à la radio en disant que ma vie
soit longue ou courte je serai au
service de la nation et du commonwealth
c'est le sens du devoir chez isabelle 2
comme eux
chez son père sa mère et cetera j'ai
trouvé que lors des obsèques du prince
philippe la voir arriver seul dans la
chapelle saint georges était
extraordinaire ben avec les stalles vide
le silence ça fait beaucoup
bon c'était soit près de 75 ans de
mariage est une jeune princesse qui
avait 13 ans quand elle a rencontré
celui qu'elle allait épouser l avait dit
ce sera lui et personne d'autre à
fraisans on était en juillet 1939 comme
cinq vrilles sera d'abord donc une vraie
histoire d'amour et le prince philip
était un homme avec beaucoup beaucoup du
mot je crois que la reine aujourd'hui
doit se sentir très seul même si elle
parle beaucoup avec charles son fils
parce que n
après les audiences avec le premier
ministre chaque mardi sauf urgence avec
des secrets d'état absolument effrayant
dit toujours que c'était la femme la
mieux informée du monde obligé de ne pas
par les médisants au premier ministre ce
que vous êtes sûr que c'est la bonne
solution vous décider mais je me demande
si pour avoir un peu d'air l'esprit
farfelu de philippe ces mots d'esprit
vaseuses et plaisanteries impossible
mais ça doit certainement lui manquer et
je trouve que le fait qu elle était
confinée à windsor était déjà très
symbolique parce que windsor c'est le
nom qu'elle choisit son grand père
georges 5 en 1917
parce qu'il était plus possible de
continuer à porter des noms de rois
allemands germanique en se battant
contre guillaume 2 donc c'était un mot
il un nom qui depuis 1040 puis guillaume
le conquérant symboliser tout le passé
britannique est alors dernière question
jean des cars question un peu piège il
ya encore des monarchies en europe
bien entendu vous le savez comment se
fait-il qu'on ne s'y intéresse jamais on
s'intéresse à la famille d'angleterre au
s'intéresse à la famille grimaldi à
monaco
mais qu'en est il de la famille belge
par exemple on va l'avoir derrière moi
regarder mais il va parce qu'ils sont
dits très rarement si on n'enraye
solaire c'est un petit pays et puis il
ya eu des histoires phares on s'est
beaucoup intéressé dans le temps au
moment de nos pôles 3 avec liliane de
rédiger le scandale de ce remariage
après le décès de la reine astrid c'est
à plus petit pays que j'aime beaucoup
personne prendre dako oui c'est plus
grand monaco mais c'est une histoire
très très compliqué et l'as ça pèse un
peu east and spa pays qui est quand même
très divisés par les les séparations
linguistique et politique et c'est
justement c'est la famille royale qui
faisait alors ça la famille royale tient
tout ça moi j'aime beaucoup le fait que
lier ce scoop son charmant il ya chez
les filles une chose intéressante c'est
que sauf révolution dans des années
proches
il y aura une jeune génération de
souveraine régnante en scandinavie en
belgique ce sera la première entre
régnante
non qu'on sort en espagne aussi ce sera
une féminisation qui va justement voyons
les les autres à la famille du danemark
oui mais voilà aussi alors qu'elle est
la plus ancienne des monarchies d'europe
à part des complexités de d'alliance
familiale où le prince philippe
d'ailleurs des d'amour avait une partie
de son ascendance danemark
oui parce que disent elles à la reine
margrethe ii doit tata son 20e premier
ministre 25e premier mise donc c'est une
notion de l'état si vous voulez qui est
différente nous nous sommes tellement
accroché à nos élections et à des délais
d'exercice du pouvoir
beaucoup trop bref aujourd'hui je pense
que ce n'est pas on n'est pas bien
veut il ya une permanence dans ces
monarchies alors il ya des catastrophes
ce qui s'est passé en espagne avait
commandé carlos pour venir mais là
regardez par exemple là pour la famille
britannique shell génération c'est une
catastrophe
1depuis elisabeth l'impression que ça va
de mal en pis ils sont de moins en moins
équilibré ils ont de plus en plus de mal
de sesca affronter leurs devoirs ce qui
est quand même la moindre des choses et
tout cela j'imagine ont des problèmes un
peu similaires et on ne s'y intéresse
pas pourquoi c'est drôle
pourquoi pas mais parce qu'ils sont très
discrets bon là c'est moins
spectaculaire les belges que la
monarchie britannique c'est évident les
monarchies du nord il faut connaître ces
pays il faut aller assez suédois gas oil
et à stockholm il faut aller à
copenhague la norvège où j'ai été reçu
c'est encore plus lointain est compliqué
pour nous avec des passes et très
complexe pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale et d attitude héroïque ou
choquant qu'on connaît mal on connaît
mal ces histoires et qui sont pour moi
passionnant parce que ça vieux fond
nord-européen je trouve que ce qui est
très intéressant c'est l'histoire de
l'espagne alors la jeune à leur chute de
juan carlos m'a vraiment consternée et
choquée par ce que il avait été
tellement formidable cette fameuse nuit
où il empêchait le coup d'état et que
l'espagne retombe dans les cauchemars de
la guerre civile
quand il était jeune mais quand il était
vieux c'était moi c'était moins bien
mais son fils se déroule bien et c'est
franco avait compris que seul sans doute
dans le souvenir d'alphonse xiii la
monarchie resterait un un ciment face
aux volontés indépendantistes déjà qui
se manifestait pour dire que l'union de
l'espagne au sens propre a été longue à
obtenir
il a fallu franco n'avait avait établi
sept mois et demi absolument il avait
lavé jezzine l'ex d'alphonse xiii oui
oui il avait choisi avait choisi ce
prince bourbon désargenté né en exil à
rome et sur lequel personne ne ne
pariait épousant une princesse de grèce
enfin j'veux dire c'était un calcul
politique
et là il faut le dire on ne va pas
refaire l'histoire rendre carlos a été
formidable 7 me du coup d'état du
colonel tejero qui n'a pas marché
c'était intéressant c'est que son fils
l'actuel souverain était à côté de lui
quand il a appelé un par un les
commandants des unités en leur disant
vous restez dans vos casernes dans vos
campement il a évité le cauchemar c'est
c'est dommage pour la fin c'est même
grave et ce n'était pas un cadeau fait à
l'actuel roi et il ya le fmi luxembourg
aussi oui c'est dans le jour nous
enregistrons c'est la fête nationale
luxembourgeoise peu j'aime beaucoup
j'ai connu le grand duc disparu et
d'être un homme fascinant
juste une petite chose sa discrétion
il avait été le seul prince héritier
d'une maison régnante
débarquant avec les américains en 1944
et il avait fait préparer une médaille
qu'il portait avec juste ses initiales
et qu'il souhaitait des funérailles
chrétiennes s'il venait d'être tué
c'était un homme très discret alors le
luxembourg souvent épinglée comme étant
présenté comme un coffre-fort
clandestins ou un parent un nivellement
que ce n'est pas faux mais avec une
famille qui est vraiment un fond
d'histoire européen depuis au moins
françois 1er le dernier lambeau du saint
empire germanique qui subsiste c'est
très amusant très intéressant sur le
plan politique c'est tout ce que je
dirai voilà une famille qu'on connaît
mal mais le grand duc que précédent
était adoré la famille très aisée mais
c'est un coeur de l'europe aussi ce sont
des européens depuis toujours les pays
bas la famille des pays bas un peu et
familles des pays bas a connu le drame
alors qu'on a connu avec leurs
fiançailles de la princesse qui voulait
épouser un allemand qui avait laissé
évidemment des souvenirs épouvantable
aux pays bas à cause de la guerre et où
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer le
souverain actuel ils sont absolument
charmant très drôle très gentil parle un
français merveilleux ce sont des gens
qui travaillent beaucoup
ils sont très près du peuple très joyeux
très cultivé mais très très gai le dire
qu'ils sont dans ce pays de marchands de
commerçants de cet univers à l'opposé de
rembrandt je dirais c'est assez
fascinant parce que ils ont tous connu à
kermesse héroïque les pays bas espagnols
c'est yoshi une belle leçon d'histoire
c'est une famille très sympathique il
n'y a pas de photo mais on n'a pas
besoin de les voir en photo les connaît
par coeur les grimaldi
oui c'est c'est est-ce étonnant le
destin de cette famille parce que je
pense que on ya huit ou dix siècles
personne n'aurait parié un heureux et
pourtant ils sont toujours là quand on
regarde la concurrence devait être très
grande allée concurrence y avait des
familles régnantes absolument partout
mais c'était vraiment tout petit et ils
ont pu y avait toujours il ya un intérêt
s'ils voulaient au départ qui a ripé
alors déjà les romains avaient constaté
que ce port en eaux profondes avaient un
intérêt maritime
et puis il ya un homme qui comme
d'habitude était géniale même si on
n'aime pas c'est le cardinal de
richelieu qui a décidé de faire
construire une marine pour la france
qu'il fallait dont des forêts et qu'il
fallait développer des forts qui s'est
installée qui a fait signer un traité
entre les seigneurs de grimaldi et la
couronne de france ce qui a été à ce
moment là le destin de monaco
on retrouve à côté de napoléon quand
napoléon débarque à golf gens et tombe
sur le pas de monaco et napoléon lui dis
je rentre chez moi aux tuileries moi
aussi ici enfin montrent assez étonnant
évidemment l'image inoubliable de la
princesse grâce que j'ai personnellement
connu qui était une femme extraordinaire
quand elle entrait dans une pièce les
gens s'arrêtaient elle le glissait
s'était elle était le le charme un même
c'est un des moments pour moi les plus
tristes jetait au figaro magazine à ce
moment là thomas téléphoné pour faire un
papier 12 pages dans la nuit j'étais
pratiquement larmes parce que elle était
tellement drôle et charmante quand elle
parlait d'hitchcock qu'elle parlait
cuisine qu'elle avait des d un sens du
devoir mais d'une élégance elle ne
marchait pas le glisser quand elles
entrent et quelque part les femmes
s'arrêter là regardez merci jean des
cars 2 va passer sous de cette émission
avec nous au coeur de la royauté ça
vient de paraître chez perrin merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
merci
[Musique]